la meta final está a la vista para tesla
el fabricante de automóviles
estadounidense comenzó a construir su
fábrica cerca de berlín hace dos años y
está por concluir la albert cooler le
siguió el paso
cool eres fotógrafo aficionado creció en
la región en su cuenta de twitter donde
habla de tesla tiene seguidores de todo
el mundo es una gran oportunidad para la
región pero también para los jóvenes que
viven aquí y que ya no tendrán que irse
para encontrar un buen trabajo
el jefe de tesla elon musk prometió que
se crearán unos 12.000 puestos de
trabajo también agradeció a los
lugareños en alemán
gracias a todos los que han apoyado a
nuestro proyecto esta fiesta es para
ustedes
a principios de octubre algunas personas
se les permitió entrar a la planta de
tesla para verla de cerca pero no todos
los locales están entusiasmados con la
llegada de la compañía en las puertas de
la empresa un grupo predice el impacto
ambiental que ésta traería
la fábrica está justo en medio de un
área de protección del agua es una
catástrofe para el medio ambiente local
si surge un problema en la fábrica el
nivel freático se contaminará y eso
afectará también a ciertos barrios de
berlín
pero en brandenburgo donde la industria
se ha extinguido en gran medida la
llegada de tesla promete un futuro mejor
los políticos locales la apoyan
desde la reunificación y así durante los
últimos 30 años ninguna empresa que
cotiza en bolsa- se ha instalado en el
este de alemania así que tesla busca
echar raíces y es un momento muy
importante para la región lo vi andando
[Música]
según él en moscú el primer test lab
fabricado en alemania debería salir en
noviembre y sería el primero de 10.000
semanales